welcome everyone for the most boring
less exciting chess games met in World
Championship match ever like seriously
ever like looking at this mat so far I
mean we had eight games okay let's see
scary bit quickly game one repetition on
move ten was the most exciting game so
far game - game - okay the petitioner
moved 20 in a bit game 3 yeah none good
better position actually didn't push I
taught it by the way that was that was
the game that I thought big matches
completely overlooked before that I
thought the match is over I did
completely cannot win Game four with
just a nun blundered on move 15 and okay
actually played quite well defending in
Game five
nothing nothing little bit more than
nothing and at some point a nun made
mistake
game 6 look at the description of Game
five Game seven we are going to see here
why why even to bother game eight well
let you have the match and go to the
next one it's unbelievable this match
like seriously there was not one game
one game that one player at some point
really got more than half a point
advantage like really I mean a nun
blundered and it was much worse than
Game four constantly wrong and it was
worse worse I mean probably it was into
very big advantage and maybe at some
point it was very big advantage but was
clearly in another favor
other than that it looked like someone
that just have heart attack and at some
point and none like you know like just
fell off the cliff in Game five six so
that's the world champion that we have
basically like someone that is playing
ping pong and instead of doing something
sophisticated the world champion we're
gonna have you know this is the net we
turn the ball we turn the ball we turn
the ball not making mistake after ten
thousand two returns his opponent will
make some mistake and he will win so but
see it's great so we are going to have
this world champion craft and it's I'm
so excited
okay the interesting part about this
game I can tell you that I was looking
at this game and if I hadn't if I hadn't
seen the score of this match I said it
but let's say I would say exactly the
same thing as Kasparov pretty much I did
I said like you look at this match if
you have never seen and you think that
white is leading +2 and needs draws
because the NAND is playing with white
and he seems like he's so happy getting
solid quite nothing position out of the
opening and Kasparov said well you wanna
win so you're playing the most solid
line you're playing Carlsen dot dot
so okay III by the way I'm in the camp
since Game one they turn unto the play
defo I think it's gonna it's kind of
history now that you played already four
games fo but he had to play d4 for the
measure I wonder why why played III
sorry why played if or not before
tonight we're gonna have game nine maybe
it's gonna play d4 or maybe just gave up
the match okay so we are having some
sort of the building defense in previous
game we've seen this line well this is
Game four well there was just this big
blunder Game six was similar stuff with
d3 but no take so he'll it took and I
said Game six because a nun had white in
Game six and seven he switched the
colors okay I mean my point I mean I see
pretty much same people that were here
in previous lectures and they can
testify and the same as been in the
YouTube that very very early into the
match I said the number of games that
Anand is going to win in the match is
going to be zero very early I mean I
actually I thought this I thought this
before the match but after the third
game I was here saying no not going to
win one is not even close to that one
just made a way to Anton so for me plus
one for Carson or plus whatever doesn't
matter Anand is not going to win one in
the way is playing here you want to beat
Carson in this position I don't think so
92 okay they've been actually quite many
games in recent years in this line
actually actually in the last year there
were many many games then I will ask you
to stop it for half a minute alright
I'll just open my chest base can you
edit it yeah because I actually have
this analyzed just so to be able to feel
in our you know we we need to at least
be able to show something okay
so if I start like dancing and jumping
in this okay alrighty
yeah so it at least we can tiny bit
discuss whatever we're gonna have here
okay
like we've said many many games in
recent well let's say just the last year
in this line not to make it too heavy
here I have it on just based on the
other computer and we can start with
Queenie - you know top Oliver gets back
or played in the Grand Prix in Salonika
Greece this year like this was played
six months ago six and a half basically
to understand this position you know
when we let's use this for tiny bit
strategy and learning chess cause they
match I I cannot make myself say
anything exciting about it so okay
white gave his light coloured bishop he
gave his light colored bishop and he has
all his central pawns on light squares
that's very logical that's the right way
it should be white most likely would
like to have a break with the move f4 at
some point we might see the night
somehow making its way to f5 in some
versions but most likely this move f4 is
reasonable some some versions differ I
mean white is not gonna win having one
point causing the fourth-ranked blacks
very logical play almost automatic is to
play c5 so then is controlling defoe and
then where is this night well where is
this night going the knight on f6 d7 and
then what me if it's only say or not
it's doing on this seven just blocking
the bishop but it's actually correct is
going to be serving the knight should be
on ethics of c6 controlling those
squares it's so logical that black wants
maximum power on the dark squares
because he already has this bishop
that's doing a lot on the light squares
so in the game that we just mentioned to
Paulo becau okay this was played Bishop
d6 Knight c3 c5 geez
idea I don't like this Jesus so much but
the idea is to be able to have some
night each fall no discovered the idea
is no night a key fall in any version
but just looks like it's weakening the
square so too much black is very very
principle in his play and objectively ok
I I think I already tiny bit prefer
black here this point is weak some
squares here Bishop e6 coming I mean ok
Black is very ok allowing Y to take this
bishop he has dolls doc those pawns on
the dark squares that are very very very
very pretty by the way anyone has a
question at any point like just please
say yes that was quick question this is
well game 7 from the World Championship
and on this white we switched on game
after game 6 he was waiting game 6 and
but this deposition that we were seeing
was from to follow Paco this year so
this was a version of Queen e2 and and
himself and cows and played like
bazillion that would be a distant number
games this year in this line like for
example an and against night each
actually 2009 this is actually very very
similar to what happened in the game
with Carson Castle Bishop g4 h3 take
take 97 okay basically nothing for white
like it's just ok it's gonna go night if
86 the double pawns are not really of
any importance it's actually important
to understand well when the double pawns
are important let's just right now see
where you have those pawns against those
okay they are holding them when when is
it going to make a difference
when can write say okay I've got
something and we are going to see how
the game went and added nothing
well you can say you have something when
you manage to exchange the D pawn for
blacks Nippon for example okay let's see
pathetically play this oh wait there is
okay just for the fun of it okay now
white can at least claim say hey I have
my Georgie on the kingside I fall
against three even this is not like you
know like huge big party but you can at
least have some idea of claiming that
you have something to play because those
four really are not doing much more than
those three I mean those positions are
kind of considered like I don't know
half a point for white in some way
because no not very easy for black to
create a passport which I mean kinda
impossible in many ways to create a
passport with those so this is why white
sometimes wanna play the phone not not
that easy mad if game was was the door
by the way speaking about recent gains a
month a month ago month and a half ago
actually in the Grand Prix in Paris
Nakamura played white against France in
a one of the top French player and
instead of castle once again we had seen
the move actually saw a castle
h3 Bishop e6 of course the pawn cannot
be taken here right because of
constantly Queen d4 right constantly
Queen D foreign f2 and e5 I'll just just
that's it
so the pawn cannot be taken
okay there was several several big I
mean all the big names all the big names
no not sever Bishop e6 okay Queenie to
nine d7 same idea we really denied the
knight on f6 is really bad because you
cannot go here cannot go here cannot go
here so the knight on f6 is really bad
you want to move it and d7 is usually
the square Bishop e3 f6 yeah for example
here in this game let's see what nah
come over play take take
he made effort to play exactly the idea
that we suggested but like I said even
that is not such a big party Castle
castle King b8 d 4 okay maybe White is
tiny better here but even that wasn't
that easy though some steel pieces on
the heavy pieces on the board maybe if
white exchange everything you can claim
tiny bit something but if Nakamura
couldn't get anything here I'm not going
to claim to get more than he did in the
position in okay many many many more
lines we can continue for a long time
I'll just mention for example Castle
right here in this position was a land
with white against Kawana Intel Memorial
2013 so it wasn't a big it wasn't a big
surprise for anyone to see this game I
mean I can mentioned oh wait
bleat bleat and normal from the Norway
and on karaoke in 2013 Carlson karaoke
in 2012 and non-comic Zurich 2013 and
uncommon in 2012 and nine hammer 2013
and so on and so on so basically they
are playing a lot this line
very very difficult you know to say hey
someone has a positive score Carlson
played this with white pieces against by
Cohen Bill 2012 Carson play this with
the white pieces against a 1-yard so you
have enough enough enough enough cows
and games here and once again you know
me from the outside you know just doing
this big commentary here for you
thinking if you're - - in a match don't
you need to come up with something that
is not as standard as possible with
something surprising well I can only
quote Kasparov that said exactly what
many of thinking and undies acting like
he's the one leading the match Knight
bTW - Bishop GFO
Castle it's in many of the other games
h3 this this is interesting
cousin played he removed it I believe
it's quite a novelty
he played Bishop h5 he played Bishop h5
the take was played in others against
Rossini we mentioned him before just
played in 2010 12 ok the game went like
these black black late Queen f6 maybe
maybe Castle and F stakes is the
possibility
I like the pawn on f6 we've seen it in
many of the games before ok
I thought it may be a false if white
can't get em oh he might be better here
actually he played a bit different okay
maybe got something maybe not he won't
Adams one with the white pieces but
maybe it may be an odd thought that he
has something here but it was Gaussian
that played Bishop Bishop h5 did kinda
look
questionable maybe or at least waiting
an eyebrow because we kind of know that
you don't want to have the bishop on g6
when this is the pawn structure that
white has like I guess the reason that
he did play that allow himself is
because he hasn't castled yet black so
if G for I guess black has some thoughts
about h5 and some dynamic play on the
Queen's on the King side in some
situation take is again impossible
take it again impossible but I I think
the g4 should have been played I think I
think that again you want to play
somewhat complicated you you you want to
get into some territory that is you know
that you have more chances to score
III think g4 is they move to play well
unemployed ninth if one which is super
duper logical black like 97 which we
have seen many many many times
93 take take g6 Bishop e3 okay
so here is the position how similar is
that position to Nakamura first in a
quite similar I mean okay like the
structure is the same the idea of why
the same in the other position Nakamura
head 2/9 of like at a knight and a light
colour bishop but let's let's assume the
bishop are being exchanged it is like in
the other game night and Bishop will be
traded does right have something here
not very easy I'm looking I'm looking at
the break wait let's say if d4 is a
possibility and it seems it's not so
because something like this and the
night might get in trouble because the
knight right now is tied to defending a
foe but he for will have constant
pressure and ideas such as h4 so H 5 H 4
are not very easy to to deal with
I mean after capture here I can show
this line capture captured mr. Houdini
himself and no other thinking that black
is actually somewhat better in this
position because the idea will be to
take on the phone.i to c5 the night on
g3 cannot move in H 5 H 4 is coming like
is white yeah but okay but then you have
one other weakness to worry about for
example let's say that I take taken play
this we see in this this is going to
take some attention from you
okay but but you will have but this pawn
will just be weak over there because
then I let's say then I will move my
knight how are you going to move your H
hook to d1 after you have already played
h4 yeah it's taking some attention from
you right taking some resources and
that's basically the thing if we get rid
of all their heavy pieces right now
let's go to the end of it if we get rid
of all the pieces all the pieces
everything probably why it is raining I
mean this is just a winning point in
game for white get rid of all the routes
minor pieces Queens
this is winning pointing in for white
because blacks fall cannot cannot create
a passport
Queen is through here yeah I guess you
can okay I will go with my f3
can i play just wondering something like
this maybe but you will have Knights III
III this is correct idea you want to
regroup yourself this way but it should
not allow you okay let me take take and
go 95 right away in this mode maybe
we need five check maybe two well check
you can go to you can go to no check
you'll have some maybe you can go to see
what yeah actually I like this idea of
yours I mean at least principle it's
really addressing what we are speaking
you want to get f3 so what should I play
here yeah I think take a 95 is
reasonable I'm thinking also about
Bishop basics but this idea probably
looks logical let's see mr. Julian no
wonder you made me thinking big time
you're stronger than Houdini that dad to
Dean his best move Queen III know it's
it's because there and now he's saying
h5 which we suggested or b6 so let's
look at the line that we looked h5 when
you play F 3 and then Bishop DC but okay
we are very much in a territory that we
looked at only one moved it's probably a
bit better than what I played I mean
this all played maybe maybe this move so
the knight can have some some ideas like
this or c5 the knight on c5 I played was
not that great but okay if white will
manage to consolidate will be very happy
the thing is that probably cannot in the
game and none didn't believe that he can
play with night on g3 so he made the
effort to bring the knight I mean but
but you played very well I mean just the
fact that you played 23 and f3
means that you really understood ok H 5
H 4 is serious all right look
88 ok he wants to fight against d4 right
so after D for the e4 d4 pawn is under
attack that's the big idea in this
position so King b1 okay just h4 I mean
I thought that h5 looks kind of
automatic reply but somehow I like it
maybe time
less in view of and then one day white
very soon one day white maybe if we can
push G for let's say pathetically push
three four okay yes something to play
for
I mean what white white really white is
less than zero weaknesses I mean he put
his pieces under the boat
so like seriously it's like it's like
looking it's like all those looking at
the position somehow it reminds me of
you know thousand stories you know 1990
rabbit tales and all those like about
some people that you know hidden their
heart somewhere on a eager Linda like it
cannot be found but okay but you also
don't get anything like I'm looking at
the position think okay what is the weak
spot for what okay I mean this is not
really weak
so really why test I mean and this is
the middlegame
zero weakness is nothing nothing black
now has tiny bit the g6 one and Carlson
is I I think just played as simple as
possible like zero weaknesses okay King
b7 okay take I was thinking you know
take with the point sometimes make sense
but but Anand already had experience in
Game six with those double pawns that he
lost with white I mean okay in the other
game just a minute to place the flow and
provoke this weakness here if oh but
yeah probably nothing here it took like
this I mean this is his idea okay so you
want to play fo fo D for something with
the pawns basically he wants to be able
to get something that he can play
against those double pawns but you can't
a 5y just just a decent move going to
the seventh rank go away from the
seventh nine I mean it's really you know
find it very bizarre that you're the
world champion -2 I kept saying it and
that's what you play he didn't play bad
but
okay fo ya changing the works so let's
see what happened of course default
queen takes before you see so white got
nothing
I mean without any you Giganta my
analysis why I've got nothing because
you have those four against and you
cannot create anything if we can have
push the pawn somewhere else okay white
might be speaking about something but
blacking is super safe and okay look D
for nothing and apparently they are not
just the world champion and the highest
rated player in the world but they also
show that they are extremely creative in
finding repetitions like repetitions in
this game of being tremendous so really
don't know if I made this game any
interesting or whatever I think I made
it the most that I could so if this if
you thought that this game was boring um
well game eight is much more exciting
you